مهم، هذا خيال بالنسبة لك،
تخيل أنك تسقط من السماء
وتركب وحيد القرن،
فلا عجب أن زاكل الصغير لديه
لقب جديد، الجميع يدعوني بالرجل وحيد القرن
الآن في مهرجان القفز بالمظلات في
إنجلترا، قفز هذا المدرب في Skydive
Langer من الطائرة في السادسة من عمره.  000
قدم يتدلى بقدميه العاريتين جاهزًا للارتطام
بالانزلاق والانزلاق الذي بالكاد يمكنك
القيام به هناك للانقضاض، يسمون هذا نعم، يجب أن تكون قد أكملت ما لا يقل عن 200
قفزة للمنافسة في مسابقة ركوب يونيكورن، حيث أن
جان لديه حوالي 2400 قفزة
صعبة لأن  إنه أمر خطير، استغرق الأمر
محاولتين،
حاول حوالي 30 من القفز بالمظلات ركوب
يونيكورن،
واقترب البعض منهم، ولكن ما كان بمثابة ألم في
الرقبة بالنسبة لليونيكورن
يمكن أن يكون ألمًا في المنشعب بالنسبة للقافز بالمظلات
[تصفيق]
أعني أنه يبدو أنك  قادم
بسرعة كبيرة،
نعم، أعتقد أنني أتحرك بسرعة 60 إلى 65 ميلًا
في الساعة، وقد رأينا لاعب القفز بالمظلات يقفز
من الطائرة وهو يركب وحيد القرن، لكن في الواقع
يسقط القفز بالمظلات على واحدة يفعلها لاعب القفز بالمظلات، وهو
أمر نادر مثل
الجني وحيد القرن  معظم سي إن إن نيويورك
أوه